[Music]
1990 the famous Bank of China building
became the newest addition to the Hong
Kong skyline with its sharp pointed
edges
soon after the building was opened the
bank next door reported huge losses and
to other businesses filed for bankruptcy
those businesses specifically blame the
design of the Bank of China building for
causing this catastrophe
why because with those sharp edges that
building shrinks the principles of Fung
Shui supposedly cutting through the
skylines good fortune it may seem like
superstition but architects from around
the world have made major design
decisions based on function decisions
that we can see and that may even affect
our lives so what is function way it's
all about creating harmony by finding
ways to connect man-made things with
nature through design using the five
natural elements metal water wood fire
and earth
[Music]
the best way to understand it is to
start small with a living room and each
one promotes something different water
can represent living flexibly and you
can include it in your home using the
color black or by introducing a wavy
pattern metal is represented by objects
made of well metal as well as the color
white you'd add fire elements if you
want to ignite passion triangular shapes
and the color red help to bring in a
little heat the wood element can
encourage personal growth and you can
incorporate that with the color green in
plants finally earth elements provide
stability and you can incorporate it by
adding heavy objects or something like a
square rug it's solid but can be refined
good for creating stronger focus and
disrupting unharmonious forces it may
seem unlikely that these practices can
bring about such major life results but
there's a reason some of the world's
most successful and impressive
architects integrate them into their
designs put simply they share the same
purpose to figure out the needs of a
person and find ways to make the space
functional this can be done by using
colors shapes textures and even through
the arrangement of things like furniture
[Music]
to see how architects use feng shui
let's start in New York City at the
famous Columbus Circle one of the first
major locations to use function in the
United States it's right next to Central
Park and the central feature is this
roundabout roundabouts represent a huge
problem in Feng Shui they represent the
water element but in a more volatile way
whirlpools
there's an endless rotation of people
vehicles and energy constantly flowing
through the traffic circle like water
without something to interrupt the flow
a whirlpool begins to form function y
experts say this can cause catastrophe
as wealth could potentially get sucked
into the hectic flow one of those
businesses concerned about this is the
Trump International Hotel
enter function master and Trump
consultant in the 90s poon-yen and her
father 10 soon she suggested adding the
now famous Columbus Circle globe which
literally disrupts the flow of energy as
people stop and gather around its
purpose is to stop the roundabout from
sucking in all the potential wealth and
opportunities for example people who may
have otherwise just kept walking are
stopped in their tracks potentially
bring in more business and therefore
more wealth the globe was installed in
1996 by Donald Trump at the suggestion
of the two function masters the move
signaled to the architecture community
that there was a new market emerging in
the US for Fung Shui in architectural
design after this the number of function
is's in new york state shot up from 2 to
65
Feng Shui is used by architects in
different places around the world for
different reasons but whether the
architect has a casual interest in it is
culturally connected to it or simply
knows it helps sell newly developed
buildings it's being used everywhere
next let's take a trip to Sydney
Australia home to the Sydney Opera House
a Fung Shui triumph by combining two
elements that seem at opposition but
actually work together fire and water it
was designed by architect
jørn Utzon who wanted to create a space
that uplifts the arts according to
Steven post function er and teacher the
sail like curves of the structure which
is literally built on water represent
that element and combined with the
triangular shapes which represent fire
in Feng Shui that prop up those curves
this combination can create a productive
balance using the passion of the Arts to
foster flexibility in its audiences and
the larger city that makes sense because
the Sydney Opera House is all about
promoting the Performing Arts hopping
over to Europe let's look to the romance
capital of the world Paris which is home
to the most famous collection of art in
the Western world the Louvre it was
designed by IM Pei the same architect
who designed the disastrous Bank of
China building in Hong Kong but this one
is a functional the Louvre includes
classic European architecture coupled
with more modern glass pyramids in the
center pyramidal structures are regarded
as a classic fire structure in Feng Shui
in its base is flat in the square
representing the element of Earth the
combination of these two elements
encourages passion through the element
of fire to fuel the need for art to
continuously evolve while the earth
element helps ground the place and
teaches us to respect the invaluable
treasures of classical art that are
already in the museum but not all
buildings can be so lucky
the Bank of China building had one of
its sharp edges pointed directly at the
HSBC building the neighboring Bank that
reported losses as a result of this
so HSBC responded with Fung Shui
adjustments of their own by installing
cannon like structures on the top of
their building a function that deflects
negative energy but experts say there
are a few relatively easy fixes that
could put the building back in harmony
Steven post says changing the
criss-crossing metal components from
white to green would promote wood energy
and making the antenna at the top red
would promote fire energy making these
changes would shift the sharp nature of
the building into a naturally harmonious
one where wood is fueling the fire
leading to success as architects and
interior designers continue to include
the practice of function into their work
you can expect to see more buildings and
landmarks with the aim of creating a
healthy harmonious city life maybe one
day they'll be able to even remedy the
growing feeling of fleeing big cities
for wide open spaces so the next time
you're out and about in your own
neighborhoods take a look around
there could be Fung Shui elements at
work and you didn't even know it
[Music]
you
[Applause]